à genoux au pied des arbres de son
verger 6 et sécateur à la main
cet homme pourrait passer pour un
spécialiste de l'entretien des arbres
fruitiers qui les raccourcis pour leur
donner ce bail pour le cerisier voyez à
la fin il a fini par obtenir une
un port qui donne du fruit parce que les
arbres qui monte aux antilles savons pas
de fruits en réalité c'est ici que
philippe bérard passe le plus clair de
son temps dans l'entreprise qu'il dirige
à châtillon le duc perçait de la société
démontre bisontine depuis 1976 après
avoir été visiteur médical ce commercial
de formation a senti que la révolution
de la montre à quartz où il permettrait
de réussir et c'est bien là qu'il s'est
effectivement révélé en fait j'ai
découvert en moi des qualités certaines
qualités je dois dire que mes par
exemple le sens esthétique le sens de la
création mais ça s'est avéré très très
très vite que nos collections étaient
des collections qui était belle le
succès de la marque hino times vendus en
bureau tabac permet alors à l'entreprise
de grandir elle est très vite complété
par certus actions ou encore go puis
vient le coup de maître de philippe
bérard le retour de lip à besançon il ya
bientôt cinq ans l'homme jusque là
réservé et plutôt dans l'ombre se
retrouve dans la lumière et assume et
chef d'entreprise c'est être capable de
assumer les difficultés les réclamations
les risques les c'est tout ça vous
n'avez pas derrière vous quelqu'un qui a
au pire si ça va mal et quelqu'un va
venir pour m'aider me protéger ou non
aujourd'hui la société emploie 125
salariés et prévoit de construire un
nouvel atelier en 2019 une grosse
pression que ce fils d'agriculteur
conjure en revenant à l'essentiel la
terre
[Musique]
c'est une chance de pouvoir avoir cet
équilibre entre avoir pu trouver des
terres allouées et puis je dirais faire
paysan c'est à la fois magie monastique
et c'est vrai que je me ressource
ça ça oxygène quoi je dirais qu'avec ça
j'ai pas besoin de partir ni d'antichute
vie ailleurs gg ici un équilibre ou donc
la thèse du gnc celle là c'est celle là
en grand et dans ce traitement surface
donc on appelle canon de fusil et depuis
la reprise de la marque que l'ip le père
et le fils sont aux commandes de la
société
chacun son secteur mais pour le moment
les rapports hiérarchiques sont
respectées aujourd'hui je dirais que
c'est un patron qui me laisse vraiment
le
le champ libre je souhaite à tout le
monde d'avoir un patron comme g et un
père évidemment à 68 ans alors que la
retraite se profilait pour philippe
bérard le boom de la société est venu
repousser l'échéance sans forcer si la
santé est là si la forme est là je pense
pas décrocher avant cinq ans c'est sûr
c'est la santé là un sourire qui signent
simplement l'envié intacte d'avancer
encore et toujours
[Musique]